[Música]
ah
si andando en esta plática preguntándose
si es posible enseñar a pensar o cómo es
que se enseña algo que generalmente
hacemos hasta de manera mecánica
entonces mi trabajo ha comenzado yo me
dedico a
sacar caras de asombro porque se habrán
fijado que cuando estamos pensando
hacemos gestos y decimos cosas que dan
evidencia de que estamos pensando como
por ejemplo llevarnos las manos a la
cara fruncir el ceño
sirve a nuestro interlocutor o
interlocutores pero estoy pensando oh
nuestro famoso y muy yucateco guay nunca
había pensado en eso
esas palabras esos gestos
nos dice que algo se ha echado a andar
a los niños y niñas con los que trabajo
me gusta decirles que me dedico a que su
cerebro se haga más fuerte y que las
neuronas que lo conforman concretamente
las dendritas esas que parecen como sus
bracitos cuando llega a nosotros
información nueva lo que hacen es
estirarse y buscar otra neurona que
tenga información parecida las dendritas
se juntan se unen y no se separan y de
esa forma nace un conocimiento nuevo es
una historia de amor para contar un
proceso bastante complejo que se lleva a
cabo en nuestro cerebro y que los niños
se entienden perfectamente
a lo largo de estos años he descubierto
que las personas aman pensar sin
importar sexo edad condición social
origen étnico aman pensar y yo me dedico
a que piensen sobre lo que están
pensando me dedicó a enseñar pensamiento
crítico
y más o menos se llegaba a la conclusión
de que para enseñar de esta manera se
necesitan de tres grandes momentos y de
eso es de lo que les voy a platicar el
primer momento consiste en generar el
espacio el ambiente para hacernos
preguntas preguntas de esas en las que
tienes que perder el control porque no
sabes lo que el otro lo que la otra
persona te va a responder preguntas que
la búsqueda de la respuesta a veces
surge poesía como la respuesta de
citlali con tres años en una discusión
acerca del tiempo había definido que lo
infinito son como las olas del mar
iñaki a los 8 haciendo un primer ensayo
definía que escribir era asentar la
punta del lápiz en una hoja y plasmar
algo inteligente o la respuesta de diego
a una de las preguntas que se ha hecho
la humanidad durante largo tiempo ya es
donde está la mente
diego había dicho que la mente está en
nuestros huesos una respuesta bastante
lógica en el caso de diego porque es su
papá de suert operista y su mamá de
psicóloga
preguntas que invitan
a cuestionarse a uno mismo y este es el
segundo momento como lo que le sucedió
al rollito
rollito con 5 años estaba en una
discusión sobre política trabajando en
la pregunta de quién manda y había
contestado pero esto está bastante
verdadera porque si efectivamente yo
mando en el lugar donde él rodó dijo eso
su maestra muy hábilmente había
aprovechado la respuesta para plantearle
un dilema que lo llevara a razonar lo
que estaba diciendo le habría dicho okey
rodó y si creo que es la que manda
manda
pegarle a un amigo qué harías
pero lo que había empezado a hacer esa
cara que antes de escribíamos
había contestado no eso es o no bueno tú
lo has dicho geo manda y manda
pegarle a un amigo no es que pegar es
malo
contestaba error la maestra que seguía
el proceso le decía ok rodó pegar es
malo siempre producto ya un poco cansado
de el interrogatorio había dicho bueno
es que pegarle a los amigos es malo fue
el momento cuando la maestra y yo muy
emocionadas con la respuesta de rodilla
la le dijimos hoy bien todo eso se
contesta ahí no nos dejó terminar de
festejarlo porque nos dijo ver como que
bien pegarle a los amigos no es correcto
la respuesta de roto
su negativa
a lo mejor hay alguien aquí que la puede
traducir como hoy es el niño le está
faltando respeto a la autoridad o que
niño tan claramente educado sin embargo
para fines del análisis crítico
la respuesta de rodo tiene
muchas aristas
si tomamos su respuesta y la vemos de
este marco de referencia histórico
podríamos decir que rode estaba actuando
como esas personas que a lo largo de la
historia de la humanidad le han dicho no
a una autoridad que quiere abusar de su
poder
o si lo miramos desde la psicología
podríamos decir que rodó a sus cinco
años alcanzado un desarrollo de la moral
en donde puede distinguir que hacerle
daño a las personas que queremos a veces
no es correcto
o
desde la educación y los estilos de
crianza y suponer que roto está siendo
criado en un ambiente donde puede
y hablar con su autoridad y llegar a una
negociación porque lo que le está
mandando no le parece correcto
rodó con su negativa se cuestionaba su
sistema de creencias pero también
cuestionaba al otro
y aquí viene el tercer gran momento
el momento de acompañar
el cuestionamiento colectivo
platón tiene una cuenta
para ejemplificar esto dice que cuando
bueno el cuento del platón relata que
habían unas personas adentro de una
caverna y que una de ellas
que estaba atada decide liberarse y que
cuando decide esto sale y se asombra de
la realidad de lo que de lo que está
allá fuera de la cueva y no se queda
disfrutando de esta realidad sino que
regresa a la cueva y le cuenta a los que
todavía están allá lo que hay
este gesto
es el que a veces quien enseña
pensamiento crítico debe de acompañar
el cuestionamiento colectivo
porque a veces
amamos pensar pero no amamos como piensa
el otro
y se vuelve un problema
este problema yo les resuelto
con otro teniendo un marco de referencia
el que elegido es el enfoque en derechos
humanos
este enfoque me permite
o le puede permitir a quien desea
acompañar un proceso de este estilo deja
de un lado su propia visión del mundo y
acompañan el pensamiento del otro
desde este enfoque
se tendría que partir de tres grandes
premisas reconocer que la otra persona
tiene derecho a pensar
respetar
la diversidad de formas de expresar este
pensamiento e invitar al ejercicio
crítico creativo y cuidadoso
cuando logré una alumna universitaria
asia la conexión entre
el neoliberalismo como corriente
económica impuesta en nuestras políticas
públicas desde hace aproximadamente 30
años en este país y escuchaba el dato de
qué
está bien que en méxico existen 10
personas que
acumulan la riqueza de 60 millones
que están en situación de pobreza
y lore entendía que esa conexión era una
de tantas respuestas a la desigualdad
que vivimos descubría que de este lo que
había elegido estudiar
necesitaba buscar alternativas
por eso la gran oportunidad de trabajar
pensamiento crítico es generar estos
espacios que permitan hacernos preguntas
preguntas que nos permitan avanzar como
humanidad
la ciencia y la filosofía la vida de los
científicos de las científicas de las
filósofas de los filósofos son un
recurso que constantemente aplico en mi
práctica
con los niños y las niñas
cuando carlitos mi hijo de 5 años
escuchó por primera vez la historia de
sócrates
ese filósofo que habían matado por andar
haciendo preguntas me había dicho así
con su cara de obviedad que hace él a
veces
es frustrante historia
frustrada yo con su respuesta le había
preguntado y porque lo ves
que lo mataron por andar haciendo
preguntas
y aquí va
mi única recomendación
y mi principal aprendizaje enseñando a
pensar crítico y reflexivamente si uno
lo quiere hacer tendrá que lidiar con la
censura y con el conflicto que a veces
lleva a acompañar estos procesos
pero después de todo esas caras de
asombro global que esperamos lograr
muchas esta tarde gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]